20 year olds stay poor because they
start trying to earn rather than trying
to learn they did a survey of high
school seniors 52 believe that they will
be a millionaire by 25. it's delusion
you can try and roll the dice and have a
one in a thousand shot of being a
millionaire in 90 days or I can
guarantee that you'll be a millionaire
in a decade which would you prefer
and so I want to give you a quick
example of two guys about the same age
that took two very different directions
in life one of them went to another guy
who was a little bit older tried to
learn the basics of editing video use
the Buddy to get a job interview and
he'd learned enough that he could get a
job offer this particular company had a
huge Suite of other people who
significantly more advanced creative
director who's done multiple big brands
that he had the ability to learn from he
gets a sixty thousand dollar offer which
is a solid amount of money for editing
with basically no experience who then
rather than accept the job he asked for
three thousand dollars more because what
he thought he had to do was earn rather
than learn the business is obviously not
going to do that what this guy does is
he starts trying to negotiate back and
forth Wheels and Deals and then
eventually gets a job to be the lead
head honcho of video editing at some
small business that has no other mentors
there's no other people ahead of him he
took the right hook in his career 12
weeks after getting into it and now they
are the ones who are trying to extract
as much from him rather than coming into
a business where he's the small man on
the totem pole and he can learn from
everyone else which would maximize for
his long-term net worth when you're
early on you learn this much and you
think you know everything and it's
something called the dunning-kruger
effect the more you learn in a specific
skill the more you realize you don't
know other guy same idea wanted to make
money but had zero skills because he's
17 years old of course you would have no
skills he decided because he talked to a
mentor who's older than him and said hey
I think you have a proclivity for sales
I think you'd be good at he said
whatever the minimum quota is that they
tell you to do an activity double it
this was a sales role and so he was
required to do 100 calls a day he did
200 calls a day why because he's not a
skill so he has to do twice the work in
order to get the same output as somebody
who's more experienced the mentor also
said go and spend as much time as you
possibly can with the number one guy
listen to everything he does and watch
what he does that's what he did and then
he proved himself as number one on that
bottom team then he got promoted he's
the youngest guy there worked as well
what he realized was that no one was
going to give him respect based on his
age Stacks his way up stacked his way up
then became one of the top closers in
the company where many people were
experts at sales and he was able to
learn from them because he was hungry
and he did extra hours now at this point
in his career he could right now
probably start a million dollar your
business or he could reinvest and so he
got another opportunity to work at a
much more prestigious company where
he'll get even bigger and better
experience and guess what he's going to
get paid less than he was making at his
current job why would he do it because
he's smart not thinking short if you go
for the earning early you stop the
learning and the moment you stop the
learning is when you decide and you tell
the universe that I have made enough
this is enough for me start at the
bottom and learn every skill along the
way
Kobe Bryant was famous for doing this
where he would do two practices a day my
name is Kobe Bryant 17 years old Fridays
and Saturdays I would go in my rec room
with my basketball and basically dribble
myself to sleep I think that that was
the best thing that could ever happen to
me because during those lonely hours in
the rap room I discovered the hunger the
motivation and the desire to be the best
possible basketball player that I could
be and he thought if everybody else does
one practice today if I do two a day I
will get better faster and in the
beginning the difference is not that
noticeable but after five years and then
10 years he becomes unbeatable whether
you're trying to get into law or you're
trying to get into accounting or you're
trying to get into sales or you're
trying to get into marketing whatever
the core activity that you do making
videos making ads writing sales Pages
actually doing sales calls whatever it
is if you do two times or four times the
volume you will get better faster and
pay down your ignorance debt at a faster
rate that compounds he has compounded
the number of hours in the trenches
learning the thing respect is always
earned and the Younger You are the more
you have to earn it and you can either
resent the world for not giving you
respect that you do not deserve or you
can go get it hustle across age gender
culture is always respected it's one of
the universal currencies respect but the
problem is that people want the respect
before they do the hospital what the
killers look like in their 20s who
become the killers in their 30s don't
look like the kid with the lambo on the
watch what they look like is hungry as
[__] to learn and work if you can humble
yourself and you realize the
dunning-kruger effect exists that you
think you know more than you do when you
start because you don't know anything
that's why Socrates said The more I know
the more I realize I know nothing one of
the smartest wisest people in the world
says he knew nothing
I'm gonna flip to my employer hat for a
second if someone comes in if they're in
the earnings season I will work you
because I know that this is the only
exchange if you come in and I know
you're in a learning season then we will
be so generous with how much we can give
and reinvest in you the exchange when
you're coming in and I have to pay you
above to get you to come here means that
I have to extract more value from you
than I pay you that's the fundamental of
business but if you come in with a
learning hat on then that business owner
understands that maybe in five years
you're not going to be there they can be
like cool how can I assist you in your
career what skill sets do you feel like
you lack I can pair you with people in
the company who are further ahead in you
and help you get mentorship within our
company and you learn for free and not
only that I'm going to pay you to learn
so the most important thing you have to
realize when you're in your 20s is what
season you are in you have to stop
comparing yourself to people who are
earning more than you because it means
that what they're doing is often
shortchanging their long-term earning
for short-term earning there is a time
for the earning but the moment that you
decide to make that Red Hook it's going
to be hard to come back because you're
going to earn more and you decide that
from here on out you can't really learn
much from people ahead of you because
they're not going to give to you the
same way you would if you were in their
business
your ability to provide value will
compound with time especially as you
start pairing skills if you think about
Jay-Z in the beginning of his career the
first thing he did was he learned how to
rap it's JT's a bad thing your time
after bigger the right Master bigger
than that Jay-Z rap so you can say y'all
support line and then he started
learning how to promote another skill
significantly more money and then after
that figured out how to do a record
label and distribute even more money and
then after that he figured out how to
recruit other artists and get them sound
on his label even more money and so what
happens is that he still needs these
early skill sets even though he didn't
monetize them hard there he monetized
them big later skills will compound if
you have one plus one plus one it
doesn't equal three when it comes to
skills if you are good at math cool if
you learn bookkeeping a little bit more
if you learn how to become an accountant
even more if you start understanding
taxes and insurance all of a sudden
you're a CFO now if you start
understanding M A and mergers entity
structures all of a sudden you're not
only a CFO you are a Rainmaker you're
somebody you can bring in deals execute
deals Etc the earning potential
difference between somebody who's an
accountant and a Rainmaker is tens of
millions of dollars per year so one of
my heroes Warren Buffett he finished top
of his class at Columbia business school
somebody finished his top of their class
at Columbia can get a job paying very
well in most places but guess what he
did he asked Ben Graham to let him work
at his investment firm for free Ben
Graham was one of the goats of investing
at the time when Warren Buffett was just
a kid coming out of college a chance to
study under him it shaped my
professional life and guess what Ben
Graham said to him when he asked him to
work for him he said you're overpriced
Ben Graham knew just as Warren Buffett
knew that even though he was working for
free it was going to cost Ben Graham
Moore to deliver all of the skills and
all of the things that he would need to
be successful than the monetary
compensation but because Warren Buffett
is smart he realized that he was in a
season of learning and not earning it he
was willing to invest as one of the
greatest investors of all time in the
thing that was most important and
valuable to him at the time himself and
he did it for free
I'm gonna flip this real quick and tell
you a little bit on my own story people
know this I finished Magnum [__] Laude in
three years at Vanderbilt I could earn a
decent amount of money at most places
graduating like that I then took a
consulting job that was paid less than
most of my other people were because I
could work directly with the CEO and so
I was going to learn more I then gave up
on the Consulting career to do Fitness
the first move I made is I asked 40
different gym owners if I could work for
them for free mind you I was a magna [__]
laude graduate vice president of the
powerlifting team I was president of the
fraternity came from a Consulting
background like I had a lot of skills
but I realized that I was going to be
getting more out of the exchange than
the person who I was working for and so
I asked to work for free he started to
employ me and he eventually started
paying me minimum wage I would have to
swallow my pride in order to take that
job but it was one of the best
investments I ever made and rather than
compare myself to the people who were
earning more than me and I'm gonna be
real with you I did and it hurt but if
you learn from one of the best in the
industry if anything you should be
paying them and the fact that they will
accept you at any price is worth it
every time it would be like me going to
Elon Musk and saying I'll be your
assistant he offers me a hundred
thousand dollars a year Alex I would
like to offer you one hundred thousand
dollars per year to be my assistant and
me being like I'll come for 200.
actually you're stupid never mind think
about how stupid that is that's the
decision 20 year olds make every day I'm
hoping that MOSI Nation you aren't like
that you're willing to make the
long-term trade because when you have
this track record this stack of
undeniable proof that you are who you
say you are you have done what you say
you've done you don't need to pretend
you don't need to front because you have
the experience and then people will
respect you because of what you have
done not what you say